okay welcome to office hours it's my
chance to meet founders and help them
solve their biggest problem in the world
with the underlying obvious charade of
me buying 6% of their company okay
let's continue the charade that I'm
trying to help people that I'm trying to
help people out of the goodness of my
heart when all I want to do is get on
their cap tables as they build a unicorn
and then get just just a tiny sliver of
that glory when they go public or get
bought Jackson you're from ki yo I'm
from ke u IO and using biometric ID to
replace keys and fobs and credit cards
and all that nonsense yeah show me what
you're working with here yes I see
you're carrying a 3d printed prototype I
think am I right yeah very student so
you're at the 3d printed prototype phase
what do I do I put my eye scan or is a
finger scan what is it you wave by it
like that and we look at about five
million points and the vein patterns
underneath your skin with infrared light
and infrared imagery to identify you and
Wow so wait a second you're telling me I
do the Jedi mind trick it's exactly as
my hand across this little box that
looks like an iPhone attached to a
little retina scanner but it's not a
retina scanner and you scan my hand
print from what six inches away
what is that fidelity three to four
inches three to four so I do a Luke
Skywalker mm-hmm Jedi mind-trick these
are not the droids you're looking for
and the door opens oh can you make the
door make a wish sound you know in
trader joe's yeah how they do different
sounds and different seasons oh they do
yeah like when you scan your credit card
huh we're gonna do that got it so this
I've never seen in the market why have I
never seen this is just a new technology
yes we've been in pseudo stealth mode we
are bringing this to market right now it
took a lot of time and energy I think
you mentioned kind of getting lost in
the in the woods yeah and a lot is all
about being a stay up now startup in my
mind we're doing really really big
things there's this technology this
biometric this new level of biometric
this is a new standard in the industry
that's coming it's been historically
expensive and so we found a way to
commercialize existing sensors the way
that big companies would buy them from
us what will this cost to deploy at a at
an office
per door yeah so we just brought our
first customer Greg which is exciting
they bought 25 units at $1,300 each one
and they're paying us about $1,000 a
month 25 units at 1,300 I'm assuming
that's a break-even for you yeah with
installation approximately does that
include not luige my I was money you
know we did not lose money break and we
weren't installing them you're not they
have to attach to the wall or do you put
it on a table next to the wall how does
it work because it's got an interesting
footprint I don't know exactly how
that's supposed to yeah but if I had to
put that on my wall I'd be kind of large
yes so there's a little bracket spot in
the back there so like a card reader or
whatever looks similar to that
yeah hidden stalls similarly so 1,300
bucks
yeah and when you make them at scale if
you were to make a thousand of them in
Shenzhen or Taiwan right now what would
the class 450 okay
$450 at scale so you could actually do
that that that's we're gonna go make a
hundred right I think in two years we
can get down to probably sub 200 so then
the interesting thing becomes a software
solution so it's really hardware as a
service has yeah so here which is not
the version of hats you get when you
have heated seats in your car and lest
anybody be confused there's that's what
different has that's hot ass yeah what
we're talking about here is hardware as
a service it's has it's just as
delightful because you get subscription
revenue from a hardware product that's
what you're gonna do right yeah you know
it's really cool about that people don't
tear stuff off their walls very often no
so the lifetime value could be very high
yeah all right so I know this business
really well because I'm an investor and
on the board of a company called density
which has a similar hardware as a
service yeah and I'm in cafe X and I've
got some scar tissue with other hardware
Crombie's I know when your question for
me what's your biggest challenge right
now yeah Jackson which is Jason with an
X is that right
completely correct yeah Wow yeah I get a
lot of Jason's like if I were picking my
real name what did you really yes when I
was born yeah wait wait no no they made
it up for you you did my born name was
JC KS Owen and I changed it removed -
pretty awesome Jeff Jackson calm I don't
eject some clang calm
very nice all right what's your biggest
issue wait your biggest issue we can so
broadly speaking we were you may I'm
right here in East Bay and yeah a lot of
Chicago on a 54 foot sailboat and
Emeryville marina oh yeah see now I just
want to let people know when I hear
people like oh why us he's personal
question when I hear like a personal
little hack like that I'm like okay this
is a nod dude like he's going really bad
and he lives on a boat but guys who live
on a boat and gals who live on a boat
they are hackers because they figured
out how to have the best of all worlds
they had beachfront waterfront property
and they pay a fifth of what it cost
y'all and they could move at any time
unless they bought a non seaworthy
vessel super seaworthy you're seaworthy
yeah and it's the ultimate hack isn't it
it is and here's it cost you for your
slept like 1,200 a month hooked into it
because I've looked into this madness
because I wanted to get a boat yeah cuz
it's a hack I want to get a boat down in
a marina mmm in like San Mateo area I
want to get a high-speed boat yeah so
that I can commute to the city or
Oakland or Berkeley it's about 12 times
a year so we VC on our dog you have a VC
on your dock multiple really so I'm
gonna have to fight that and they do
that they do they zip down yeah such a
great hacker Charles all right what's
your biggest challenge yeah broadly
speaking I think we're doing something
and I think there's a few parts of it
that we haven't touched on we have a lot
of inbound interest even though we try
to stay out of the media and try you
have to do things except for this yeah
inbound interest room investors or
customers no customers great and what we
have not been able to achieve I think is
taking that interest and quantifying it
in a really interesting way going into
fundraising around which we have to do
and a lot of that is because the
customers are larger than we can
reasonably service right now given the
3d printed nature of the product the
small nature became the good news about
that though is even if you had a
customer let's say like Google mm-hmm
who has too many store
door fronds yeah they would if they were
gonna test this they would pilot it
anyway yeah so even though you can't
service them the first contracts gonna
be for ten doors anyway no they're not
gonna give you ten thousand doors yeah
so it's kind of cool yeah yeah so you
think pilots pocs are a critical path or
well I'll be honest I there's enough
here for someone like me to make an
investment on a small scale if you have
one customer yeah so and I'll tell you
why the degree of difficulty in the
hardware you're gonna make me cry no
I'll take the very difficulty I
understand the degree of djenne cry
first on this program usually people cry
not because they're touched but because
they're beat up this is great as a first
no but the degree of difficulty in
hardware we all know is super hard and
so for you to get to market and get a
customer who's paying thirteen hundred
unit for twenty units it's a very that's
enough one that's a significant pilot
that's not a [ __ ] curse on my own
pocket that's not a BS pilot it's the
legit pilot how did you get it is that
the question I would ask hustling we
took every opportunity we could say yes
okay LoZ and one of those were good
answer but did you call them or good day
find out because you suck they read a
story on TechCrunch and the contact we
got in stage every place we could one
those was a plug and play event got in
Mexico so in Mexico you did a pitch
event you know and somebody in the
audience said I want it and they when
you didn't drop the ball they were a GM
of a huge like new facility in Mexico or
in Mexico perfect that's enough all you
need to do now is crush that one
installation and have that person not
shut up about it and have it work these
at 20,000 times her fan so if it's
perfect and it doesn't fail I think like
you should come to our accelerator it's
like a perfect kind of moment for you is
to go to an accelerator and then go out
to the venture community that would be
like the easy way for you to do it or if
you want to skip the accelerator process
you probably need to get to three pilots
or four pilots so I think you have
plenty for an accelerator to accept you
know four seed funds to accept you they
probably would want to make sure that it
wasn't a fluke
and that you had three pilots so usually
more pop we have more pilots now of that
scale though this one was just a
legitimate deal it's every door every
turnstile on the building yeah so the
whole you have two more pilots yeah we
have additional pilots including with
like the largest yeah so then
fundraising becomes a full-time process
for you for three to six months she have
to be prepared for that no we focus on
that a lot in our accelerator launch
accelerator but you could do it yourself
too which means if you go through our
accelerator you get introduced to well
over a hundred investors who hear your
pitch and then you basically just have
to follow up with all of them and close
two or three of them yeah so you get to
a close rate of let's say one to three
percent you're good because then we
would follow on with them in all
likelihood you raise that five hundred
to two million dollar seed around or you
can do it yourself which means you have
to email cold email 500 investors
I'd say 250 to 500 mm of those half will
open it of those half will reply now so
in other words you get 20% reply rate if
you're lucky so if you do 500 you might
get a hundred replies if you're lucky if
it's a really good pitch like a video
and I'm a bitter about the product a bit
about the traction so let's say you get
those hundred replies and then you
convert the hundred applies into twenty
in-person meetings and then you have to
pray that you get five of them to take a
second meeting and pray that you get
past mark with two so you're talking
about 200 250 20 50 to 500 reach outs
you have to follow up with almost all of
them because nobody replies to the first
email you got to do like three replies
and that is why it's a six-month process
I tell people so just be prepared for
that and at the same time you have a
co-founder yeah - perfect so if you have
a co-founder you have to tell your
co-founders one person is gonna focus on
fundraising one is gonna focus on
existing clients and pleasing them and
one is gonna focus on the product right
and you have a division of labor there
that becomes very smooth and the other
two people have to step up if you're the
fundraising one and say the business is
gonna grow and be strong during that
process make sense yeah I am delighted
to have met you this is a very
compelling product and kudos to you it's
gonna be a race to build the tools that
matter on the back end so people could
really care about the tools
and so having that API are you building
an API for the pattern because a lot of
people already have authentication
systems and the turn off what's great
about this is you don't have the cost of
badges or fobs and those fobs get very
expensive and they get lost and our
security concern and there are
management headache the good news is
nobody's losing their hand hopefully
hopefully hopefully no business has to
experience somebody losing their hand
yeah I think I mean it's pretty dark but
Luke Skywalker lives completely yeah I
mean it's kind of got a whole Luke
Skywalker thing to it I've tried that
pitch before and yeah turn people off
but I like know your audience all right
yeah well winning today's conversation
I'm okay I'm really infatuated by what
you're doing and also that you live on a
boat all right
boat hacked by the ways have friends
with boats I know what boat is the
fastest boat that I could go in the bay
and is there a speed limit in the bay I
don't people you can go like oh that's
fast
I know people going that fast uh what
what kind of boat goes 50 miles per hour
is that like one of those little where
they call them scorpions or something
doesn't like it looks like a big Boston
Whaler I'm sure one of those lights so
fast
that's ridiculous yeah the problem is if
you hit away wrong you die a wave you
die if you hit like you go along go
along this like a big yeah what is the
safe speed you know thirties maybe othor
tees yeah but still has to crow flies
between like East Bay and South Bay
you're fine right compares that ten
miles yeah I was thinking about to go to
Warriors games or go to Oakland Airport
like I would like to just what I would
like to do get in at Santa Monica San
Mateo yeah
area so budget for marine is there and
zip over to the Oakland Airport and park
of the Oakland Airport and take it over
to my flight and I like all of it ok
another business idea for you later yeah
more to come on this week in startups
[Music]